welcome back i'm not gonna take a slight
tangent and cover a topic that i think
this is probably the single most
important video um that really anyone
can watch i go to all of these parties
or i go see family and um you know my
wife and i right now we live in northern
california and we're renting um and and
i like to point out by choice and i have
family members why don't you buy it's
you're at that stage in life that's a
major milestone all of this there's a
lot of pressure to buy and when i tell
friends there i tell them well i'm not
going to buy because you know i think
i'm
pretty pretty convinced almost 100
convinced that housing prices are going
to revert back and i'm going to do a
bunch of presentations to justify why
they will but then my friends they'll
just throw out you know the statement
that i hear from them that you hear from
real estate agents because obviously
they want you to buy is that well isn't
buying always better than renting
and i think that kind of common wisdom
comes out of the notion of when when
you're when you have a mortgage or when
you uh when you borrow money to live in
a house every month that that money that
you give to the bank is kind of going
into savings that's that's the
perception well when you rent that money
is just disappearing into a vacuum and
in this video i'm going to
well i guess work through that
assumption and see if if that actually
is the case
so let's say i have a choice let's say
there are two houses
two houses
is house number one and this is house
number two
and let's say that there are identical
houses these are
you know three bedroom tattoo bath town
houses some place in in silicon valley
which is where i live and uh i have a
two choice i want to live in one of
these houses i'm indifferent to which
house i live in because they are
identical so living in them is the
identical experience
i can rent this house so i can rent this
house
for three thousand dollars a month
three thousand a month
and or i could buy this house
buy this house for a million dollars
and let's say that
in my bank account right now let's say i
have 250 000 cash
so let's see what happens in either
scenario let's see how much money is is
being burned
so in this scenario what happens i'll
put i'll take i'm renting so in a given
year let's just see how much money comes
out of my pocket so in a given year i
paid three thousand
three thousand times twelve months
so i lose thirty six thousand so i'll
put a negative there because that's what
i spend in rent thirty six thousand per
year
and uh
per year in rent
and then of course i have that two
hundred fifty thousand
two hundred fifty thousand i'm going to
put that into the bank because
i have nothing else to do it i didn't
buy a house with it
and let's say that i can in the bank
well i don't know let's say i put in a
cd and i get four percent on that so
let's see 250 that's what 10 000 dollars
i think 0.04
right i get 10 000 in interest a year on
that
so i get 10 000 so plus ten thousand
dollars a year
in interest
so out of my pocket for the privilege of
living in this this this house in
silicon valley with beautiful weather
out of my pocket every year goes twenty
six thousand dollars
twenty six thousand dollars so that's
scenario one
so what happens if i give in to kind of
the the peer pressure of family and and
realtors
and the mortgage industry
and i buy this house for one million
dollars well i only have two hundred
fifty thousand dollars which is
more frankly than most people who buy a
million dollar houses have but i have a
two hundred i have two hundred fifty
thousand dollars cash
so i need to borrow seven hundred fifty
thousand dollars so i take out a
mortgage
for
seven hundred and fifty thousand dollars
and i'm gonna do a slight simplification
and maybe in a future presentation i'll
do kind of a more complicated one and a
lot of mortgages when you pay your
monthly payment most of your monthly
payment at least initially is the
interest on the amount that you're
borrowing and you pay a little bit extra
on that to bring this value down that's
called paying off the principal you can
also take an interest-only loan but the
component of the interest is the same
when you essentially when you take a
traditional mortgage kind of a 30-year
fixed every month you're paying a little
bit more than the interest just to take
down the balance
but for the simplicity of this argument
i'm just going to say that we're doing
an interest only mortgage and then maybe
with any extra savings i can pay down
the principal and that's the same notion
and right now if i do 25 down and i'm
buying a million dollar house
you know so i'll have to take a 750 000
mortgage i don't know what a good rate
is six percent
so let's say at six percent six percent
interest
six percent interest so to live in this
house how much am i paying just in
interest
well i'm paying 750 000
times six percent a year
so
times .06
is equal to 45 000 in interest
45 000 in interest that's coming out of
my pocket
and of course on a monthly basis that
means an interest per month i'm paying
just to get an idea i'm paying about uh
3 700 3 800 an interest a month my
mortgage actually might be something
like 4 000 a month so i pay the interest
and then i pay a little bit to
you know chip away at this at the the
whole value of of of the loan and it
takes 30 years to chip away at the whole
thing and over time the interest
component becomes less and the principal
comes more but for simplicity this is
the interest that i'm paying 45 000 a
year
and then of course at a party when i
started explaining this it's like aha
but interest on a mortgage is tax
deductible and what tax deductible means
is that this amount of money that i
spend on on on interest on my mortgage i
can deduct from my taxes i can tell the
irs that i make forty five thousand
dollars less than i actually did
so if i'm getting taxed at let's say
thirty percent what is the actual cash
savings well i'll save thirty percent of
this i'll have to pay fifteen thousand
less in taxes how does that work well
think about it let's say i earned
a hundred thousand dollars in a year and
i normally have to pay thirty percent so
i normally pay thirty thousand dollars
in taxes
right this is if i didn't have this
great tax shelter with this house
now i have this interest deduction so
now i tell the irs that i'm actually
making
that i'm making fifty five thousand
dollars a year
and then fifty five thousand and let's
say my tax rate is still 30 percent it'd
actually probably go down since i'm but
let's just for simplicity assume my tax
rate is still 30 000. so now i'm going
to pay 16
in taxes
to the irs
so how much did i save
in taxes
minus
plus 30
is equal to so i saved 13
500 from taxes
from being able to deduct this 45 000
from my income so let's say tax savings
tax savings
the tax savings plus
13.5
k
now what else goes into this equation do
i get any interest on my 250 000 well no
i had to use that as part of the down
payment on the house so i'm not getting
interest there
but what i do have to do is i have to
pay
taxes
on on my property in california out here
we have to pay 1.25 percent in taxes of
the value of the house
so what's 1.2 so taxes is property tax
and that's actually tax deductible too
so it actually becomes more like i don't
know 0.75 or one percent so let's just
say one percent just for simple
simplicity property taxes
so one percent
times one million
that equals what one percent of one
million is another ten thousand dollars
a year in property taxes and notice i'm
not talking about what part of my
mortgage goes to pay principle i'm just
talking about money that's being burned
by owning this house
so what is the net effect i have
i have
a
13 500 tax savings
i have to pay 10 000 actually i have to
pay a little bit more than that but
we're giving a little bit of
income tax savings on the deduction on
the property taxes
and then
i actually have to pay you know the
forty five thousand dollars of interest
that just goes out the door so i'm
paying forty one thousand five hundred
dollars
so i'm paying forty one thousand
five hundred notice none of this how
none of this 41 500 is building equity
none of it is getting saved this is
money that is just
being
burned
so this is a completely comparable value
to this 26 000
so in this example in this example is
not that far off from real values i
could i can out here in the bay area i
can i can rent a million dollar house
for about three thousand dollars but in
this situation i am burning every year
forty one thousand five hundred where i
could just rent the same house for 26
thousand dollars out of my pocket when i
adjust for everything
and then people you know a couple years
ago said oh but houses appreciate and
that's what would make it up but now you
know very recently we know that that's
not the case
in the next video i'll delve into this
in a little bit more i'll see you soon